like I think for us what we try to find
is sort of two levels of intelligence we
try to find people who are book smart
so who just have raw intelligence and
then what you also want is to be able to
find people who have street smarts
so if you can find a mixture of both and
where you've got individuals who have a
high level of book smarts and a high
level of street smarts I think that's
actually unique because what you mostly
find out there is people who are either
just very smart on the book side and
then you've already find people who are
just very street smart and it's the
mixture or the combination of those two
talents that I think separates at least
for us those are the individuals who are
trying to find so the higher your level
of raw intelligence a higher your level
of street smarts that's how you're going
to end up getting a job at our firm
yeah and look I think we've made a lot
of mistakes I mean I wish I could tell
you we didn't make mistakes I think
we've made a lot I think ultimately the
the real issue ends up being one of
personality I mean it's you you've got a
large group of people how does everybody
mix how does everybody work well and
does having that individual add to the
team or does that having that individual
detract from the team and in the
beginning you might think it would add
and then you sort of find out through
sort of the interaction that it isn't
really that beneficial I think that sort
of you know that's happened a number of
times I think the other one is you sort
of even though somebody you believe has
raw intelligence you quickly come to
realize that on a practical level
they're not able to make decisions I
think one of the things that you find in
this business is that people are very
good at telling you why you should do
something and why you shouldn't you know
the next step is okay I understand that
now should we buy it and I think it
takes a different personality or
different people to not to be able to
analyze it but then also to say look at
this price I'm a buyer so I think that
you need to sort of see how people
develop and you find that people are
able to develop into that role or you
find that people can't develop into that
role
I think it's horrible it's not that I
don't think it's hitting more than that
it's there's been a huge preoccupation
or focus on making money as opposed to I
think when I was growing up the focus
was how do you make it a better world
and today it's not how do I make it a
better world it's how do I make my world
better which I think has huge
consequences for the society that we
live in and that I think for me I've
tried we have five children we've tried
to push our children into something that
that isn't sort of in the finance sector
yeah and that you've got to try to sort
of help others and try to help the world
and try to make a difference so yeah but
it's easy to say and it's very easy to
say and I think I think it's hard when
you're the individual and you've got and
you're extremely bright you're gonna
look at and say well I can help the
world or it can help Society or I can go
help myself and I don't I don't think
it's up I don't think it's up to us to
decide but I think the reason that
people do that is the differential in
what you make is too great right now it
used to be I think when I graduated if
you went into finance maybe you made two
times as much or you made three times as
much as another job and therefore that's
why you saw it a lot of people doing the
other jobs I think today the
differential isn't three or four times
it's sort of 10 20 30 times so that
differential is so huge that it's hard
for people who are young to say I'm
going to give that up
you